>> Hannity: LOOKING FORWARD TO
YOUR BOOK SARAH HUCKABEE GREAT
TO SEE YOU.
HERE WITH MORE FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR LARA TRUMP GOOD TO
SEE YOU BOTH.
LAURA I'LL START WITH YOU THE
INTERESTING IS THERE WAS A
DEBATE AND I PLAYED IT TOO MANY
TIMES WILL PLAY AGAIN FOR YOUR
FATHER-IN-LAW SAID WAIT A MINUTE
COME HERE TO GET RID OF OIL?
WOW THAT'S REALLY BIG WHAT HE
JUST SAID DID EVERYONE HEAR HIM
SAY THAT?
HE PREDICTED ANOTHER OCCASION.
REPAYING FIVE, SIX, 8 GALLONS
FOR GASOLINE.
I WILL ELIMINATE FOSSIL FUELS HE
SAID NOT ONCE, WE HAVE ON RECORD
SAYING FOUR TIMES.
SO HE'S ACTUALLY FOLLOWING
THROUGH ON WHAT HE SAID HE WOULD
DO AND I DON'T THINK MOST PEOPLE
RECOGNIZE THAT PART.
>> WILL THEY OUGHT TO IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT JOE BIDEN HAS
FOLLOWED THROUGH ON AND IT'S
HURTING AMERICANS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP TALKED
ABOUT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
JOE BIDEN EVER BECAME PRESENT IN
THE UNITED STATES AND WHEN HE
SAID THAT ABOUT THE GAS PRICES
TIED ABOUT SIX, SEVEN, $8
GASOLINE PER GALLON PEOPLE SAID
THAT WILL NEVER HAPPEN IT IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW ACROSS OUR
COUNTRY AND IT'S ONLY 18 MONTHS
INTO THE JOE BIDEN PRESIDENCY.
WHAT ELSE CAN
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP PREDICT?
HE PREDICTED A RECESSION ON THE
RISE IF JOE BIDEN BECAME
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY LOOK AT HAPPENING WITH
OUR ECONOMY DUG UP A HIGH PRICES
DELEGATE THE INFLATION THE LOOK
OF THE FACT THAT PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE THE DISCRETIONARY MONEY
THEY USED TO HAVE TWO GO ON
VACATIONS TO GO TO A MOVIE, GO
TO A RESTAURANT.
THAT HURTS THE ECONOMY ACROSS
THE BOARD AND IT'S A BIT OF A
WATERFALL EFFECT WAS THAT LEAD
TO?
LIKELY A RECESSION.
EVERY EXPERT HAS AGREED ON THAT.
YOU ALSO PLAY SOME OF THIS COMES
A MOMENT AGO OF THE HYSTERIA FOR
THE MEDIA OVER MY FATHER-IN-LAW
WALKING DOWN A RAMP BUT DON'T
FORGET IT WASN'T JUST THAT IT
WAS THE TIME AND TIME AGAIN
GETTING THE WHITE HOUSE DOCTOR
OUT FOR THE MEDIA TO ASK ABOUT
TWO SCOOPS OF ICE CREAM.
AND LOOK I CERTIFIED ANYTHING
WITH JOE BIDEN ON IT'S TRUE.
HE IS THE REPRESENTATION OF
AMERICA AROUND THE WORLD AND TO
HAVE A GUY CAN EVEN WRITE A
BICYCLE QUITE FRANKLY IT IS SAD
TO SEE THAT OUR ALLIES SEE THAT
COME OUR ENEMY SEE THAT IT'S
JUST ANOTHER WAY THAT AMERICANS
LOOK WEAKER AND IS WEAKER UNDER
PRESENT JOE BIDEN.
>> Hannity: I THOUGHT ABOUT
YOU AS A NEW WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY WHEN JOE BIDEN TRIPPED
BUT THREE TIMES GOING OF
AIR FORCE ONE ON AIR FORCE ONE
SHE WAS ASKED ABOUT IT SHE SAID
IT WAS VERY WINDY OUTSIDE SO I
TO KNOW WHAT'S WORSE?
THE FACT THAT SHE FELL OVER
THREE FULL FOUR TIMES OR THAT
THE WIND KNOCKED HIM OVER?
THEN SHE SAID LAST WEEK THIS
PRESIDENT HAS SO MUCH ENERGY I
COULD BARELY KEEP UP WITH HIM.
HE MUST BE IN REALLY BAD SHAPE
BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE ANYONE
KEEP UP WITH THEM.
>> YES, IT IS ABSOLUTELY
PATHETIC.
EVERY TIME I COME TO THE PODIUM
WILL NOT EVERY TIME, BUT MANY OF
TIMES I WOULD BE ASKED ABOUT THE
SECRET THING THAT DONALD TRUMP
HAD.
DID HE HAVE A STROKE?
ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE JUST
TOTALLY OUT OF LINE TOTALLY
FALSE IT WAS A STANDARD ROUTINE
VISIT BUT THE PRESS WILL
SPECULATE AN OVER AND OVER AGAIN
ABOUT IT.
THE SAGA IN THE NEAR TIMES THEIR
HEADLINES THEY WERE REQUESTING
HIS HEALTH AND THEN THE SUBJECT
LINE RIGHT UNDERNEATH IT SAID
THAT THEY STRUGGLED TO LIFT A
GLASS OF WATER SEAN THIS IS THE
MAN WHO I HAD A HARD TIME
FOLLOWING AROUND THE FIVE
RALLIES IN A DAY, FIVE RALLIES
THEY GO AFTER MIDNIGHT.
THEN WHEN I THINK THAT HE'S NOT
CAPABLE OF FIVE RALLIES IN A
DAY?
I THINK SO.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> Hannity: WHAT IS THAT
LAURA?
>> MAYBE ONE FROM HIS BASEMENT
AND RALLY IS A VERY LOOSE TERM
IF YOU HAVE EIGHT PEOPLE IN A
ROOM.
IMAGINE IF DONALD TRUMP TRIPPED
EVEN ONE TIME GOING UP THE STEPS
OF AIR FORCE ONE.
>> Hannity: IT'S VERY WINDY
OUTSIDE WHAT WOULD THE REACTION,
WHAT MIGHT IT BE OF DONALD TRUMP
HAS NO ENERGY LIKE JOE AND YOU
SAID WITH A STRAIGHT FACE I CAN
KEEP UP WITH THEM.
>> YES THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT
BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
IT'S A SLIGHT HYDROPLANE THAT HE
HAD WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY THE CASE
SOME OF THOSE RAMPS AT RALLIES.
VERY SLIPPERY.
WHILE IT WASN'T RAINING OUTSIDE.
WHAT WASN'T RAINING THAT MUST BE
ALIVE.
NO SHE'S THE BASIC FACT THE RAMP
IS VERY SLIPPERY BUT THEY WILL
MAKE EVERY EXCUSE IN THE WORLD
FOR JOE BIDEN.
>> Hannity: IF YOU HAD
SNEAKERS ON YOU MIGHT HAVE THE
CASE.
LAURA YOU HAVE THE LAST WORD.
>> WORK HERE AS WELL I WILL SAY
ACTUALLY RIDE A BIKE QUITE OFTEN
I DO TRIATHLONS ACTUALLY AM
LOCKED INTO MY BIKE SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT IF YOU ARE
CLIPPED INTO A BIKE SOMETIMES IT
CAN BE A LITTLE HAIRY WHENEVER
YOU STOP HE WASN'T CLIPPED AND
HE HAD TENNIS SHOES ON SO LOOK
AGAIN I JUST THINK THAT THIS IS
A REALLY SAD REPRESENTATION FOR
AMERICA BECAUSE IMAGINE
VLADIMIR PUTIN, KIM JONG UN
WATCHING THE VIDEO OF JOE BIDEN
FALLING ON A SPIKE WOW WHAT A
BAD MOMENT FOR AMERICA.
>> Hannity: YOU DO TRIATHLONS
I JUST TRY TO WIN BY A BIG
MARGIN.
I DON'T KNOW.
YOU AR